queen elizabeth is taking a few royal
duties off her plate and shifting some
things to son prince charles
the queen doesn't like to let anyone
down here's what we know a source
confirms to et that the monarch's duties
have been formally revised this comes as
the queen continues facing mobility
issues which forced her to sit out
multiple events in recent months
and now our source explains the queen no
longer has an official list of duties
rather family members and especially the
prince of wales are stepping in to help
carry out the workload
the health problems that the queen is
suffering are clearly concerning no one
wants to see her struggling these duties
include the state opening of parliament
and royal fans might remember back in
may when the queen missed this event to
what buckingham palace called at the
time quote episodic mobility problems
it's hugely significant having the
prince of wales stand in for the queen
because
as head of state
addressing parliament the queen's speech
is the most important constitutional
role for the monarch this is the first
time that prince charles has ever stood
in
and done this for the queen i think it
would have been a very difficult
decision for her and a very painful
decision if you've ever watched the
state opening of parliament it's a
pretty taxing event i mean not not only
the world press watching and there's a
fair amount of walking there are steps
involved
then in june after the queen experienced
quote some discomfort at the trooping of
color she was absent from multiple
events related to her majesty's platinum
jubilee celebrations
and as prince charles steps in to
fulfill more of the queen's duties it
remains to be seen if there'll be more
responsibilities handed off to the
future king of england i think the
reality is we are going to have to get
used to more of these the queen often
doesn't know how she's going to feel
until she wakes up on that day she has
these mobility issues that means she
cannot stand for long periods of time
some days she can't even walk i think
when you reflect on the past year it's
been a very difficult and trying year
for the queen she lost her husband of 73
years prince philip her consort and i
think really now we are seeing how much
she feels has lost and of course she
suffered from covers earlier on in the
year she she made some remarks to some
nhs workers that you know she really
suffered with the exhaustion that a lot
of people experience when they have
coven back in november she sustained a
back injury which meant that she had to
pull out of appearing at the cemetery on
remembrance sunday again we saw the
prince of wales stand in for her there
so it's not been an easy year by any
stretch for the queen
[Music]
you